SHAZIA MAKHDUMI: So
I'm Shazia Makhdumi,
and I'm part of our Google
Play Apps and Games BD team.
And I lead our effort
for kids and family apps.
So how many people here are
kids and family developers?
Excellent.
So if I'm blocking any
of you, just let me know.
So I always like to start
by showing-- and some of you
may have seen this,
but this is kind
of when you think about building
great kids and family apps,
this is what we're trying to do.
If you want to play
the video, please.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-1, 2, 3.
[DOG BARKS]
[CHILD GIGGLES]
-It says you'll get--
-Now do we need butter?
-Uh, no.
The other way.
Like that.
That's terrific.
For this one we
fold it like this.
Wow.
What we cover.
-I need to cut your hair.
Where is the black one?
-Oh, it's in my eyes.
Is that what my hair looks like?
-Yeah.
-Yeah?
-3.
-Yeah.
That's right.
-I did it!
You do that one.
-All right then.
-That's it.
You want it to go all the
way in nice and clean.
-And he said to us, why do
you sit there like that?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
SHAZIA MAKHDUMI: I've watched
that video so many times,
and every time I get goosebumps.
But so what we're
here to do is help you
guys build more of those
moments for families,
and Google's made
a big investment
in the kids and family space.
How many people here have heard
of our Google Play for Families
program?
We announced it Google I/O. OK.
So that's quite a few
people in the audience.
Sorry, let me try and
get to the next slide.
So it's basically a new
discovery experience on Play.
So a separate section for
kids and family content
where you can opt in to being
in that section in addition
to being in the main Play Store.
And what that does
is it allows parents
to go to a particular
place where they want
to search for content for
kids, either by browsing
top collections for kids,
or by age group, or even
popular characters.
So I'll talk a little bit
about some of the key elements
of what we've done in that.
So again, search results
are more relevant.
So for example, if you do a
search for, let's say, music.
In the Family section,
as you can see,
the results are going
to be very different,
because we understand
that you're looking
for kids and family content.
And it's only going to give
you results from the apps
and games that have been opted
into our Families program,
whereas the same search
anywhere else in Play
gives you very
different results.
And on that related
search note, no matter
where you are, if you're doing
a search-- and as you've known,
Google really knows search.
So if we understand you're
doing a search for kids
content-- so educational
games for kids, or apps
for three-year-olds, or
in this case coloring
for kids-- the results you
will get will be boosted.
Or the apps and games that are
created for kids-- because we
understand it's a kids search--
are going to get a search boost
and will show up
high in the results
no matter where
the search is done.
So again, search, which is a
really main way for parents
to search for content
for their kids,
in addition to
browsing or characters,
we've put a lot of
effort into making
sure we get it right to get
your content in front of them.
And I mentioned
characters earlier.
We know characters are very
important to kids, right?
Everyone has their
favorite character,
they want all the
content, they're obsessed.
I have two boys,
seven and eight,
and they've been through
their different obsessions.
But what we did was we wanted
a place-- from a parent
perspective, you have one place
to go and get all the content
you want related
to Peppa the Pig,
or related to Dora, or Elmo,
or "Frozen," or what have you.
So you have your apps
and games, you've
got your movies and TV
content, you've got your books.
And so this is a way for
parents to find that content.
And then for developers,
like yourselves,
who have invested in
licensing, it really
gives a chance to get
your licensed content
in front of users
in additional ways
than them just searching for it.
And then lastly, we've also put
in a lot of tools and controls
that make it easier for parents
to find great safe content
for their kids.
So for example, we
have content ratings
that we launched
earlier in the year,
and everyone in the store-- so
not just kids and family apps,
but everyone-- has
a content reading.
And you can only be
in the Family section
if you have an E or E10 rating.
We also let parents know
which apps or games have
ads or in-app purchases
in case they care.
If you're a parent
looking for something
in a particular
category, or you want
to see if it's age
appropriate, we
have badging that
helps you get there.
And then finally, we also
have put in more password
protections or password
controls for reducing
accidental in-app
purchases by kids.
So that's kind of on the
design and development side.
We're also investing a lot from
marketing and the promotions
side.
We're really trying to get more
users to the Family section
and then in front
of your content.
So for example, of
course, a lot of email
and social sort of
marketing campaigns,
we're working with
curators who are
curating expert
collections on Play, doing
a lot of seasonal themes.
And then we actually
did a first of its kind
physical event with
digital content in New York
a few months ago with content
from some of our key partners
where, as you can
see in the picture,
kids really enjoyed working
with the physical and digital,
similar to what you
saw in the video.
So we've talked about the
design and development part,
but from our
perspective, working
with a lot of people
in the audience
as well as from
the store itself,
we got some insights on that--
how do you build a great app,
how do you market
it, monetize it?
And I wanted to share that with
you, including the experiences
from some of our developers.
So some of this may
seem really obvious.
Thank you.
You're understanding
your audience.
And in the kids space
it's a little bit tricky,
because you've
got two audiences.
You've got the
parent, who's going
to be the purchaser
of the content,
and you've got the child,
who's going to be the consumer.
And you really need to
please both in the case.
Parents are looking
for educational value.
They care about something
that stimulates their kid's
creativity and allows
them to explore,
but kids are not looking
for boring, dry stuff that
is "educational."
They want to be engaged.
So you really need to kind
of walk that fine line.
Another thing that I
tell developers is,
try not to be all
things to all people,
because it really
isn't possible.
We know middle schoolers
are different from toddlers,
but even there's
a difference been
like a five-year-old
and an eight-year-old,
or an eight-year-old
and an 11-year-old.
So at Google our
research has shown--
think about the key audience
that you're going after
and really optimize
for that key audience
for their developmental levels,
for their language ability,
for their motor skills, and
really get it right for them.
And that's why we
have age groups,
as you can see, in
the Family section
where you can opt your app up
to two adjacent age groups.
Also, involve kids in
your research early,
like even as the thinking
part of it, so to speak.
Budge Studios, which is one
of our partners we work with,
has hundreds of kids
involved all the way early
on from testing.
They do play testing, they do
focus groups, online surveys.
And really when you
think of the apps,
make sure the end of
it-- what comes out--
is something that the
audience cares about.
And this is also
especially beneficial,
because these early
kids and parents who
are engaged with
your content and have
been with you from
the start are going
to be your most avid sort
of proponents and customers
and influences in the
space telling other kids
and parents about your content.
And kids especially
are very visual,
and you want to really
capture their imagination
and hold their attention.
And part of how you do that is
through large, colorful icons,
illustrations, characters,
screenshots, and videos
that are high quality.
In a very informal survey
we've done with kids
and we asked, what's the
main thing that you look
for when you choose an app?
And I was thinking it could
be a lot of different things
with my adult hat on, and the
number one answer actually
came back as the icon.
Kids choose an app
based on the icon.
How many people are
surprised by that?
Maybe I was the only one.
Because I thought,
oh, well, what
does it do and does it matter?
And I had my parent
hat on, I think.
But anyway, so
make sure you think
about what works for them.
And also especially think
about kids' vocabularies
and their finger
size-- so small words,
large fonts, lots of color.
The Smart Study, which is
one of our partners in Japan,
actually says that
they use no text.
They only use images
in their menus,
and they also have
large enough buttons
that kids who can't read or
have very little motor skills
are still able to
engage and interact.
So you need to make education
fun, otherwise it won't work.
Because remember the
parent also needs
to be convinced that this
is something that they
want to purchase for their kid.
So it needs to be educational
kind of in an appealing way.
And [? IntelligeOA ?], which
is one of our most successful
developers on the Play
platform for kids,
really thinks
about-- they're very
ruthless about, is this thing
adding educational learning
value to what I'm doing?
So even if it's a really
cool 3D effect or something,
if it's detracting from
your value and learning,
they just don't put it in.
Also, together with
that, though, you
want to make it simple.
Simplicity, clarity are
really sort of paramount.
So Avokiddo when they were
designing Thinkrolls 1 and 2
told us that they took out
all the complicated scenarios,
and the complex UIs, and
the multi-screen levels,
and they just kept
it really simple.
Because for kids to be engaged,
it has to come naturally.
It can't be from kids
and parents poring
over manuals trying to
figure out, oh, my god,
how does this thing work?
They're going to abandon it
before they figure it out.
And then again, as you probably
heard in the earlier session
today, focus on quality.
Quality really matters.
Quality matters because
people pay for it.
You can see the jump in
revenue just with the addition
of a single star.
But in the kids space
it matters a lot.
Because when you're
buying for someone else,
as a parent who is
buying for their kid,
they want any signal
that tells them
that your kid is
going to like this.
And they use ratings as one of
those signals to say, oh, wow,
this is highly rated.
I think chances are high
my kid will like it.
So you want to make
sure that, again,
back to your loyal users,
your initial beta users, what
have you, make sure
people who love
your app or game go into the
store and give it a rating.
So now we've talked about
designing a great app,
but now how do you monetize it?
And monetization, as I
think we're all aware,
is tricky in the kids
and family space.
So these are some of
the models that we've
seen for kids apps--
subscriptions, ads,
in-app purchases, premium.
I'll talk about them.
They all have their
pros and cons,
and I think that you'll
find something that suits
your content the best.
So premium-- so what's
great about premium
is every time someone gets
something, you get money.
They download it,
they pay for it,
and that's revenue in the bank.
But it really works well if
you are a well-known brand,
if you spend the money to
establish yourself as a brand.
In fact, Toca Boca
and Sago Sago actually
do really well in this.
Because when something
new comes out,
the user knows the quality
of what they're going to get.
Try before you buy works
in anything in life.
That's why we have
return policies,
and you want to check it out
before we commit to it forever.
Why should apps and
games be different?
But in the family space, this
matters a lot because back
to the question that I
was asking earlier-- when
you have someone buying
for someone else,
the stakes are higher.
You want to give them
signals that they want it.
So another piece of
research I was reading,
parents apparently were like,
I would spend $99 on something
that I know my kid will
love and use and engage
with for a long time,
but I don't want
to spend $0.99 on
something they'll just
get bored with in 10 minutes.
So how do they know that their
kid is going to enjoy it?
So this is a model
that works really well,
because the parent
has a sense that, yes,
my child will like it.
But then the pesky
part of this is,
I'm constantly
getting notifications
to spend more and spend
more and spend more,
and then I need to purchase
this for the next level.
StoryToys has actually
done a great job
in solving for this, where
they make the content free
initially, but then a
single in-app purchase
helps you get the
rest of the app.
So they get the benefit
of the child trying it out
and the parent knowing
that their child is going
to enjoy the content, but
without then notifying
the parent again and again
on multiple pieces of content
they need to buy.
Subscriptions is also becoming
very popular in the kids space.
So actually I want
to do a quick survey.
On the kids developers
in the audience, how many
have premium apps?
OK.
How many have in-app purchase?
How many have subscriptions?
How many have ads?
So subscriptions is
getting very popular.
And of course, the
good news about this
is a lower cost of acquisition
for the user, which is great,
and then recurring revenue
stream for the developer,
because then they can continue
to invest in the product.
But part of the
challenge here is
you need to have something new
in there, or something fresh,
or some way that parents
are willing to continue
to pay on a recurring
basis, because they're
getting something.
By the way, if you
do subscriptions,
just sort of as
an FYI, you don't
have to process
financial transactions.
Google takes care
of the checkout,
just like we would in premium
or in in-app purchases.
And while this is not
necessarily a business model
per se, I want to
touch on IP licensing.
How many people here have
licensed IP from others?
And this is part of
why for that investment
we've actually made
character pages.
So while this is really
great in the sense
that, yes, you get a
sort of target audience,
sort of preexisting audience,
in fact, for the brand.
You've got marketing of the
brand already being done,
and it helps you
with the challenge
of use-acquisition discovery.
But then you also have a
certain standard or quality
of the app that you
need to adhere to,
because fans of the
brand expect that,
or the brand owner is going
to have some control over what
you produce.
And obviously,
also the economics
are going to be different.
So something to
think about if you
go into the licensing space.
So we've talked about
designing the app,
and now you're going
to monetize it.
How do we get users to the app?
And how do they know
that they want it?
So one of the key
things for this
is create a compelling
store listing,
and especially in
the kids space,
I was talking about icons
being really important to them.
So make sure that it's
something that's appealing.
Make sure that if someone is
looking for someone like you,
they actually find you.
So the title needs to be very
clear, because then you show up
and stand out in search results.
In your store listing,
first, describe very clearly
what it does.
And then you can add all
the accolades it's won,
but it should be very clear
about this is what I am
and this is what I'm not.
And now that you have
people's attention,
have compelling
screenshots and videos,
because that's what's
going to then convert them
from getting to that page to
then downloading, installing
your content.
How many people here have
tried our A/B tests and store
listings yet?
OK.
So it's something we
launched at Google I/O.
And I think just
across the board,
you've probably heard in the
earlier presentation, also,
people are seeing great
success with this.
So what happens, for
those who don't know,
you can actually test
any part of your listing
through A/B tests and
see what works better,
if it's icon, or
different title,
or different
graphics, et cetera.
And BabyFirst actually has been
using this really aggressively
and found out that when
they changed their icon,
they actually got
10% more installs.
So they changed it
permanently at once.
So I would definitely recommend
using this for something that's
as important as an
icon in the kids space.
And then developer
pages, another thing
we launched at I/O, and
this is a way for you guys
to build a brand for
yourself on Play.
So how many people here
have developer pages?
So for those who don't,
I would definitely
encourage you to look at this.
Because you can have a banner,
an icon that represents
your brand, a featured app.
And also importantly, when
you do marketing campaigns,
especially if they're
not about a specific app,
you can then direct people
to your developer page
instead of having to decide
which part of your content
you want to direct them to.
And then we've all heard the
saying it takes a village.
It takes a village also
to get the best apps
and games to kids.
So build the
community, get users
who you know who
love your content
to leave reviews on there.
Especially in the kids and
family space-- for those of us
parents who have
probably also done
this-- where you hear from other
parents what they like and you
go check it out, or kids hear
from kids what they're playing.
So this is a place
where parents want
to read what other
parents are doing
and use that as a way to find
something that their kid, who's
similar, might like.
And also respond to reviews--
if users have left reviews,
if they like something, if
they're giving you feedback,
respond to them and really
create that connection
to build your village.
Now, how many people
have a channel on YouTube
for their apps and games?
OK, good.
That's actually higher than when
I talked about this in the US.
So kids are on
YouTube, we know that.
I think there was an increase
of 200% in our family channels
just on YouTube.
Kids are connecting
with other creators.
Kids are putting
user-generated content.
Kids are watching
gameplay from other kids.
So you want to be there.
You want to have
your own page where
you have game
trailers, or gameplay,
or you can even have
user-generated content,
or give out tips,
or inform people
about new products in there.
And now we have something
that's cards-- when I say now,
I actually mean a few months.
This has been out
for a little while.
But it's an evolution
of annotations,
where within the
video itself you
can have a card directing
people anywhere,
including to your app.
So if they're watching
a video for the app
and they must have it
then, literally with one
click they just go
there and get the app.
And then lastly, you need to
be where your audience is, so
promote on
family-friendly channels.
So if it's a parent
blogger, or the moms groups,
or other communities, because
these influences and curators
are really important.
They're going to help
you build that audience
and get in front of the
people that you need to reach.
So do your best
to figure out who
these influences for
your particular regions
or your particular
content are and get
them to tell their
audiences about your app.
We're actually also doing that
on Play in the Family section
with expert collections from
experts like Levar Burton
and other entities where
they are talking about apps
and games they like and
helping validate your content
to other users.
How many people already are in
the Design for Families program
on Play?
So given the number
of kids developers,
that's actually a
very low number.
So if you guys are not, and
you are in the kids and family
space, I'd encourage you
to get more information
at
developer.android.com/families
on the program.
But then also if you go
into the developer console,
and you literally under the
All Applications section
go into the Pricing and
Distribution section,
and just check a
box to say, I want
to be in Play for Families.
And what that does is it
also puts your content
in Play for Families, and
you get all the benefits
I was talking about earlier
regarding search, et cetera.
And you also are wherever you
are in the regular Play store.
So it's like double-dipping.
You're not taking away from
one to be in the other.
I can't believe it.
I finished actually early.
I never do that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]